[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
tunisia's parliament
is suspended for a month demonstrators
rival camps from different sides of the
political divide
have been protesting
some outside spilling over into violence
once again the country is in turmoil
on sunday people took to the streets in
several cities in mass
anti-government protests
less than 24 hours later president kai
syed
made a bold decision he froze parliament
and ousted prime minister hicham
machichi
i find it surprising how some people are
talking about a so-called coup
i have followed the constitution the
conditions were met
and among these conditions there were
procedural terms and
all of these conditions were respected i
then invited the prime minister that i
have dismissed
and informed him and then i called the
house speaker
and i told him that i will be resorting
to article 80 of the constitution
after which i declare the exceptional
measures and the presence of permanent
danger
but there is no constitutional court to
decide whether the move was legal under
article 18.
on the streets tunisians are calling for
change many
fed up with a political stalemate an
economy in crisis
high unemployment rates and the
mishandling of the pandemic
the anaheida party which holds the most
seats in parliament
has recently bought the brunt of their
anger
we have this political crisis amidst the
the worst
health crisis that we have ever had
indonesia we have about 100
people dying every day from coronavirus
and then we have also a huge economic
crisis
so this political crisis is extremely
dangerous because
people you know are exhausted uh they
are scared
and nobody knows exactly where we are
heading
amid political turmoil and civil unrest
security forces stormed without a
warrant the officers of al jazeera in
tunis
and expelled the staff
they closed the office without providing
any reason a group of men
came in wearing security and civilian
clothes they broke into the office and
took the keys
and said they were the instructions
a spokesman for the un secretary general
gave his reaction
we're dismayed by these uh reports uh
and we hope that all reporters
including the ones that al jazeera will
be able to go about their work without
harassment
and we want to make sure that as we have
the situation on the ground in tunisia
that press freedoms are respected
with the fear that tunisia could slide
back into a full revolt
similar to the 2011 jasmine revolution
the eu
and the us are calling for calm and the
un is following the situation closely
but a decade on from the revolt that
brought democracy
tunisians are divided on what direction
their country should take
laura burden manly al jazeera